I am the world's rina most renowned
expert on scientific papers because I
have absolutely no experience writing
them I do hope that they will still be
peer-reviewed no matter what form they
take because I think that peer review is
still correct me if you disagree but I I
think that it's good to get feedback and
sort of have some quality control
because the sort of scientific blogs
doesn't strike me as having the same
same sort of quality assurance level as
typical sign to something that I would
call a scientific paper so I'll ignore
the topic of scientific papers and I'll
go back to the history of Python because
that's the only thing I'm an expert on
these days so in 1990 I was a pretty
darn experienced and prolific programmer
I worked for a small outfit named CWI in
amsterdam it's actually a non-profit
brand by run by the Dutch government as
an educational institution and I had
worked there for
probably six or eight years by then as a
programmer on a couple of different
projects mostly cranking out large
amounts of C code
my first project at CWI was actually as
a programmer on a team that was building
a programming language it's a
programming language that no one has
heard of except when they dig into
pythons history because I think we had
one user outside CWI and two inside CWI
but we spent three years building the
language and all that time as I was
trying to figure out how to implement
various parts of the language
implementation I constantly came up with
ideas to make the language better by
adding something or taking something out
and
language designer a guy named Lam bear
mertens
who sort of took it upon himself to be
my mentor for much of that time every
time I came up with proposed improvement
to ABC he very patiently explained why
that was a bad idea not a single one of
my ideas made it into the language
except that except for the name
basically the language survived three
years of implementation effort unchanged
when I started on the project that was
named B but the B was cursive and it was
supposed to be the name of the variable
when you open the variable the name of
the language would come out and then we
had a brainstorm and we couldn't come up
with a good name and that's how we chose
ABC which in Amsterdam sounded a better
idea than once I visited the United
States and looked in the phone book
anyway so ABC was a wonderful language I
loved it very much but it was cancelled
after three or four years of
implementation effort and I moved on to
project named amoeba which also very few
people have heard of except if they
studied history of distributed operating
systems because amoeba was one of the
first micro kernels and there is a ton
of literature including several very
good PhD theses that came out of the
amoeba project my contribution was as a
programmer we try to with a few
programmers we were trying to create
applications for amoeba and amoeba was
so different from UNIX that it was
easier to create our own applications
than to try to port UNIX utilities even
though we had the full unique source
code from Bell Labs available to us so
that was very tedious and one day I
thought to myself oh I really wish that
we could write these applications in a
different language something more like
ABC porting ABC all
so it wasn't really a good option
because ABC was not extensible and it
would have an even harder time than the
typical UNIX application in doing
anything useful in that particular
platform so and and and and this really
sort of all comes down to a terrible
lack of common sense and a very poor
judgment on my side I thought that in
three months I could implement a
programming language from scratch and my
manager wouldn't mind because this was
absolutely not what I was being paid to
do but my manager was on a sabbatical in
on the west coast of the US and had a
lot of free time because my my social
life was kind of in the dumps so I did
actually after three months I I had a
working prototype and I showed it to my
colleagues and I showed off simple
things like well look here's a very ball
and you put a value in it and you add
something to it and you print the value
and you could define little function and
I have arrays and hash tables
implemented and everybody was oh and uh
and can I use that and so I was
encouraged and then I showed it to long
bear mutants and I think the second
thing he said give me the keyboard and
the second thing he typed made a be made
Python crash he was that kind of person
he he had a very sort of good insight in
what the weaknesses of a system could be
now that crash was fixed the next
morning of course I really have to fast
forward because I want to give her know
sometime to but within a year Python was
sufficiently popular within CWI that we
decided to do an open source release
except we couldn't call it open source
because that word had not been invented
that wouldn't be until 97 or so but we
did it release we did it on Usenet and
because there was Usenet at the time
Python was much more easily
the distributed then ABC had been in the
sort of the previous decade because I
remember traveling to the US with 9-inch
now a nine track mag tape in my luggage
which would be mounted at various UNIX
systems throughout the country where
people would then get the source code
for ABC and that was just a snapshot
there was no source control there was no
FTP sites even that you could use to
send things around so that that was one
of the things that that sort of worked
against ABC when it was trying to gain
popularity so I had done some simple
releases of libraries to Usenet before
so I was familiar with a process I was
not familiar with that particular
outcome because immediately my inbox was
overflowing with feedback and requests
for features and bug fixes and patches
and sort of immediately people said well
we want more of this
so I spent well I guess this the next 28
years or so trying to give people more
of that first by doing a lot of coding
than by sort of letting other people
help with the coding letting other
people create a community that was not
really my strength but when people said
well we should create a news group we
should have a conference we to do other
things
I said sure do it and apparently that's
a good way to create a community to sort
of encourage people to scratch their own
itch not just when it comes to code and
so before I hand the mic to Fernando
sorry it's still mine I want to I want
to talk about some of the earliest
memories I have about now not about
coding about specifically about
adding support for scientific data sets
to Python in the mid-90s when I had
moved to the US and we had started
having regular Python conferences I met
a guy named Jim you Union who was also
an incredibly prolific coder he also had
the advantage of having gone to MIT
eventually we ended up hiring him he
created something that when he called it
he created it he called the Jay Python
but for various copyright reasons it's
now known as jive on years later he also
created something named ironpython which
was a Python implementation on top of
microsoft.net but in the late 90s before
he did Jay Python he wrote something
called numeric which was the predecessor
of numpy and it had a lot of the same
things that numpy had the implementation
was just a little cranky er I think
numpy was sort of when numeric became so
popular that it required a rewrite numpy
became that rewrite and so Jim knew a
lot more about scientific data
processing so he knew that Python arrays
were not very efficient because every
floating-point value in Python is not
taking up four or eight bytes but
probably 32 or so because it's an object
and it has a reference count and a type
pointer and memory allocation overhead
and so if you have an array full of
those you also in addition have all the
space needed for the pointers to those
objects so an array of a thousand
floating-point numbers would not take
like thousand floats in C is like four
thousand bytes in Python that would
probably be 40,000 bytes or so so Jim
had come up fourth unit Python was very
extensible one of the things ABC was not
and so it was fairly easy to add a
floating point array constructs to
Python but Jim had some other plans and
he also wanted to support other popular
data types in particular complex numbers
and so he pleaded successfully to add
complex numbers to Python he also
because he was doing a lot of wild stuff
with large arrays of numbers he did a
lot with slices which is how you sort of
take a part of an array and he invented
the ellipsis notation that you can use
to say well in all the other dimensions
just do everything I forget if it was
also behind the sort of extended slices
where you can can give us try it but it
wouldn't be surprised if that was also a
request that came out of numpy so then
if we fast forward to I think around
2005 or 2006 numpy had been created as
numerix replacement and Python 3 was in
the works and an enterprising young man
named Travis Travis Oliphant came to me
at some Python conference I believe and
he asked for a better way to pass arrays
of floating-point numbers between C
extensions we get into a lot of detail
but he wrote a very complex
over-engineered
proposal named pep three one one eight
which because I thought well he's the
expert on numeric arrays I read it over
it all read like okay it didn't have
internal inconsistency so I accepted it
I think it took five years before most
of that was actually implemented but we
do have support for all that now and I
think numpy is more successful because
of that and really I want Fernando to
take over so that will also
have some time for questions thanks
great oh and Dennis so I'll try to sort
of give a similar counterpart to that
there's some interesting parallels in
the early history and the patterns I was
a graduate student in physics in
Colorado in 2001 flailing terribly on my
own my PhD at the time and having been
fired by my first advisor having been
picked up by a second advisor which is
not a great career move on your fifth
year to the grad students in the room I
don't recommend it and but one thing
that I had or was a very complicated
pipeline my PhD was analyzing data from
supercomputer simulations of particle
physics and and I had a big hodgepodge
of literally language books on my desk I
had for the Pearl the big pearl book I
had a UNIX book because I my adviser was
an absolute wizard she was a magician
with all concet and brought the most
complicated and most elaborate or concet
scripts and I had an ideal book in a
Mathematica book and the Kernighan and
Ritchie C book and so I realized I was
probably spending far more time
switching between programming languages
than getting anything done and my office
mate says you should look into this
Python thing it's kind of like pro but
nice and and so I and you can use it
interactively and this is gonna be
important and I played with it and I
remember reading the basic Python
tutorial that ships with the
documentation and and just falling in
love with it what happened was I was a
reasonably reasonably competent Perl
programmer at the time had written some
code that actually picked up a little
open source Stanford thing for making
like web pages of pictures of galleries
of pictures and and within 24 hours of
using Python of just reading the
tutorial I knew how to do things in
Python not just that I didn't know how
to do them in Perl but I didn't know if
they were possible in Perl right and to
me that was the sign of a good tool it
was a sign of a clean design I thought
if in 24 hours I can be this proficient
with this tool and I can keep it in my
head there's something clean about its
design and expressive about it that I
really want and I wanted
my everyday tool but what it had missing
was a better interactive environment and
this comes from kind of the two cultures
that we have Guido came from a culture
of software engineering and I came from
a culture of scientific data scientific
programming and scientific data analysis
were for me the computer was really a
tool to look at data to look at a
problem to think about a question so the
interactive workflow was really
important and that also included things
like give me quick access to the
operating system give me quick access to
changing directories the opening files
to running a script but then typing code
interactively one variable at a time and
Python has a basic shell but it's fairly
it's fairly basic nothing wrong with it
it served its purpose and I looked
online and there were two other projects
out there there was a blog post by a rat
from The O'Reilly Network about two
other systems one from a grad student at
Cal Tech called the lazy lazy Python and
one from an oceanographer in Germany the
soon at Caltech was named Nathan gray
and Yanko Hauser was an oceanographer in
Germany who had written something called
IPP the interactive Python prompt and I
emailed both of them and I said hey
you've both written tools for
interactive computing in Python
I also have this thing called ipython
which was the beginning of a little
souped-up shell for Python do you want
to join forces together and they both
gave me more or less the same answer
they said nope too busy right now
got work to do go for it it's open
source do whatever you want with it
so from the very start ipython with a
Python was born as a collaboration it
wasn't my work it was really the spirit
of people putting their stuff out on the
Internet and will being willing to share
it I told my advisor this is going to
take an afternoon not 28 years but 18
years later here we are still so we have
trust us equally on the quality of our
time estimates I also disappeared it
wasn't what I was being paid for I came
very close to not graduating but six
weeks later I emerged basically from a
sort of twenty hours and I 20 hours a
day
coding binge where I stopped going to
the depart
and it's kind of a mess but out her out
was ipython 0.1 which I announced a
Korean complaint Python in December of
2001 it was a very similar process it
was I mean I really wasn't a bad place
with my PhD but what happened was they
put this thing out and immediately
people my god what about this what about
this idea what the mailing list at the
beginning was my personal email I
literally put this out and I said if you
have any questions email me at Colorado
dot edu and immediately people began
providing feedback ideas and that that
was pretty exhilarating actually to
basically realize that maybe this PhD
thing isn't isn't going so great but
there's something I can do and there's
this community of other people who want
to use this tool and who want to build
it a couple of years later I did
graduate by the way I've met faculty at
Berkeley now so there is it works out in
the end but but I a couple years later I
traveled to a conference where I met
Travis Oliphant and Erik Jones and kind
of the early crowd of the scientific
Python world this was when numeric I was
still using numeric I at that point I
was a postdoc in Applied Mathematics
that's you Boulder writing software for
PD basically developing methods for
partial differential equations on top of
numeric end with a lot of hand written
C++ and Fortran code that was precisely
possible to integrate because Python was
extensible in this manner I went to this
conference which was an outgrowth of
basically Jim Higgins work and this
community was now beginning to call s so
the first versions of that conference
had maybe eighty or hundred people who
got together at Cal Tech once a year
with some support from the Hubble Space
Telescope because astronomers were early
adopters of Python as a tool for science
and what happened was I basically found
my people right I found my tribe these
were other scientists there were
astronomers there were scientists
Travis did his PhD in EE and he had done
a post up in medical imaging at the Mayo
Clinic I think so people who came from
different scientific disciplines but who
had this common interest in building
open source tools for science together
and for all of us Python had this
interesting
set of features that resonated back from
that very first day with me which was
very expressive very high-level very
easy to think with we could use it
interactively which really was critical
for our workflow and the kind of
questions that we were asking and with
this clean extensibility model that
meant yes Python a list of Python
floating-point numbers would be a
terrible way to represent scientific
data but we have this opening will have
this hatch that let us write C code that
gave us numeric and it's evolution in
two and anon PI that allowed us to link
in the decade's worth of
high-performance well-tested numerical
codes in Fortran that could all be made
available because you could link linked
with them linked them through a C API
and that made it viable to have a modern
ecosystem with a high-level tool that we
all loved and that we were all kind of
really really excited to use and with
most of the performance bottlenecks at
least a way to tackle them it wasn't
perfect
there continues to be debate and there
can we can see people continue to
iterate on ways of working on the
performance issues and better ways to
express that but the point was there was
a way through and that community really
began to grow and it there was a very
interesting dynamic with what I would
call kind of the core Python community
meaning Guido the people who went to
Pike on that these were two parallel
communities but they were Co evolving in
interesting ways and there were
conversations that happened across and
we'd already mentioned the influence of
the public's numbers etc the counterpart
is that we learned a lot we learned a
ton at various levels technically there
was the fact that we as scientists
didn't have to be compiler experts we
didn't have to learn how to write a
programming language we basically had
this other entire community that had
that as their job and they were good at
it and they were willing to talk to us
right it was possible it took work you
had to write perhaps you had to go
through the real governance process but
they were willing to talk to us they
were willing to listen to our needs and
to implement those in the core language
and at the same time that freed us to
work on writing things like a Python or
numpy or matplotlib for data
visualization or symbolic programming
like Simba or the entire Syfy stack and
now the vast kind of ecosystem of other
tools that exist in that world we could
focus on that and sort of trust that we
had this foundation that we sat atop of
that's a different dynamic that for
example the art community has nothing
wrong with it but it emerged through a
different historical pattern our was
developed by statisticians and
effectively the same team builds the
core language the core infrastructure
and all of its extensions it's basically
all in one world this this was this was
a different dynamic and I remember
having slides when I started sort of
evangelizing Python as a tool for
research where I made the point in the
2004 2005 2006 when we began really
pushing these ideas out in the
scientific conferences of saying look
today the job of scientists is actually
getting much more complicated in that as
a scientist you may need to interact
with the database engine you may need to
parse and process nasty complicated
plain text files with regular
expressions you may need to expose your
compute engine over a web as a web
server to talk to some other remote
service etc and say you're gonna have a
ton of things to do
that go beyond writing number crunching
Fortran codes right and so you want to
do that in an environment where people
who know what they're doing or building
all those tools and for us Python was
that right Python was the one of the
models of the languages batteries
included meaning you install Python and
the standard library has a bunch of that
stuff out of the gate you don't have to
do anything else there may be fancier
versions of maybe almost each of the
tools in the standard library maybe
somebody has developed a more
sophisticated richer but the core one is
probably pretty good for a solid start
and that was huge right because it all
of a sudden meant that scientists could
tackle far more complicated use cases
and problems with this rich foundation
that we weren't responsible for
maintaining so this this is kind of a
technical part of that dialogue with
this community but there was also a
human side that that at least for me
personally was super important which was
learning how to run an open-source
community
right and both the human aspects and the
software aspects but but not the
specific libraries but rather the
software development processes of those
communities so we were as scientists
okay the idea of sharing your stuff that
wasn't so weird when you publish papers
it but the notion of collaborative
software development online processes
for doing that effectively things like
unit testing and version control and all
of those things we learned them from
just lurking on the Python mailing lists
reading interacting with them
we were always welcome there I
occasionally would post on either
complex Python or even the core Python
mailing list and a number of our
scientists occasionally kind of peek our
heads in there if the current if it's
relevant and we learned a ton we learned
a ton from watching how we don't manage
managed kind of the growth of that
community the growth of the conferences
and even as more complex social issues
being an emerging issues of diversity
issues of inclusion issues of conduct
all of those things we always basically
followed sort of what was happening in
the Python community as a way of
learning is the vitamin in that sense
was pretty much ahead of us in many in
many ways on issues of reproducibility
of the course
scientific worth well I remember giving
a keynote at PyCon 2014 I think in
Montreal where I was basically saying in
many ways the open source ecosystem
embodies the ideals of scientific
research better than we scientists do in
terms of making their stuff tested
making your bugs publicly available
making the process for that something
which is exposed to the entire community
having processes that automate a good
amount of the checking and validation
and that ensure that problems don't come
back
many of the things that we claimed to do
in the scientific world are in many ways
done more cleanly by the open-source
software community and that dialogue has
been extremely important I don't know
today the discussions on reproducible
research and the David Donoho and John
Clare about and Buchheit quote that we
all have in our talks women from
Stanford about reproducibility and
whatnot that we've been kind of
parroting for 20 years that today is
kind of part of the zeitgeist you see
editorials and science and nature and
whatnot about those issues
I'm not sure how much people realize
that a lot of those ideas we pulled very
very strongly from the open source
community and from Enya was that meant
from Python I mean obviously other
communities had similar flavors but for
many of us because Python has been so
important in in research we were drawing
that knowledge from the Python community
so I don't want to go into kind of a
full history of what came after ipython
there's plenty of talks about Jupiter
online so if you if you want to see
either the 15 minute or the 20 minute
version or the 30 minute version or the
40 minute version I have them all you
can watch those online so so I think I
think it would be I thought it would be
more interesting and more valuable here
precisely to sort of have this
conversation how our communities have
learned from each other I hope we
scientists have also contributed use
cases to Python a richness of users of
challenges of performance constraints of
ideas today for example at UC Berkeley I
was mentioning to Rosemary I spent last
year teaching the core data science
courses for our new major in data
science the upper division course has I
was I had 850 students the lowered of
course foundations of data science has
13 1,400 students these courses are
reaching basically more or less all of
the entire Berkeley campus all of that
stuff is in Python and so Guido in 1999
wrote a grant proposal to DARPA called
computer programming for everyone did
that didn't get funded right dinner okay
so this was in 1999 it and and I I would
I would say that today we may have a
version of that in sort of data science
for everybody that non-baby focus just
on programming but also on the layer of
data and analysis that at least at
Berkeley were doing it and it would be
unthinkable if it wasn't because we have
this entire open stack that starts in
Python and has non PI that at a tie
everything up to up to the high level
tools on which we can deploy these
courses these educational materials and
so for at least for me it's been a
hugely productive kind of dialogue now
of almost 20 years I have learned a huge
amount it literally made my career
possible and I think we we continue to
these communities continue to learn from
one another the one thing that I do want
to say about Jupiter is that I
definitely wasn't the inventor of
Jupiter I may have hidden from my
advisor and told her that it would be an
afternoon in 2001 for a Python but what
we know as Jupiter today is the work of
a huge community and it would be
unthinkable if it wasn't not just those
other two people who gave me a seed of
code for ipython in 2001 but especially
people like Brian Granger and min Reagan
Kelly and everybody who came after that
with whom we've built what is Jupiter
today both technically and in terms of
the human community and we do have
people who straddle the two for example
one of the directors of the PSF is an
engineer called Carol willing who we
don't know is very well she is also part
of the equivalent kind of directing body
of Jupiter a core contributor part of
our steering council so we even have
kind of human links that that are deeply
embedded at the core of both community
like Carol willing it seems to me that
this is a tool which is serves several
purposes it's used by the developers as
a way of expressing what they're doing a
good way to interact with complicated
supporting systems the various tools of
them exist in the environment of the
Python system but it's also a very good
way of writing a paper and in fact I can
see where given the vast number of
options that you want to explore when
watching when doing a export reading a
complicated computer science paper or
economics paper or whatever you you want
to explore the data that's there the
algorithms themselves and you want to do
this dynamically and so presenting the
information to your readers through a
tube
book is in fact a better way of
publishing information than writing a
paper and is this this is a replacement
for the paper if we can get everybody to
do it and the the interesting thing
about it is that they're all the the all
the Jupiter systems are in some sense
compatible and so the papers can be
executed in a variety of different
environments and tested much more
broadly and students or researchers can
experience the the problem of of
discovery and explore ideas which they
would not otherwise be able to do static
papers are kind of boring I read a lot
of them papers that are much more
dynamic they're much more interesting to
read so any other if people started to
adopt this is there a journal yet it
wants submitted in Jupiter form so not
not quite to my knowledge though there
might be something other but as far as I
know we don't have quite any specific
journal that says we can take a direct
submission in this way but the the
toolchains for conversion of notebooks
into publishable formats are getting
better and better there's a tool called
pan doc out there which was written
ironically by the chair of the
philosophy department at UC Berkeley
it's written in Haskell and it's this
lovely Swiss Army knife of document
conversions and thanks to the work of
folks in the Jupiter community as of
version 2.6 that came out a few months
ago it recognizes notebooks and that's
important because the moment pan doc
recognizes a given format in maps it
into entry it's internal abstract
representations something like the LOV
Mir for the compiler geeks in the room
then it can spit out any any of its
output formats and so now now with this
a one line or you can say pen doc - -
from food I PI and B - - to foo - docx
and you get a word for a clean well
formatted with figures with equations
word version
of a notebook same for a la tech same
for HTML so that all of a sudden begins
having having this we've had converging
machinery in the past something called
env convert that could convert to logic
and HTML but by going through panda all
of a sudden the machinery gets a lot
richer and more powerful and we've been
collaborating and talking with John
McFarlane about that we also do have
conversations with journals and with
scientific publishers about this there
are companies that are building kind of
the interactive stack and that are
working with I Triple E for example so
there's a start-up in New York that and
that is working and that has connections
with I Triple E and is working on some
of this idea basically bundling bundling
notebooks as part of the publishing
process so I think we will get there
that's certainly our vision and that's
one of the reasons why we thought of the
notebook format as something that should
be first of all independent of the
programming language itself so even
though we happen to be Python people and
most of what I do is in Python we wanted
that the basic idea of interactive a
document that combines natural language
with interactive computation happening
in a block of code there's nothing
Python specific about that idea and it
didn't you could imagine expressing it
anywhere our protocol encodes that with
the language of being just a parameter
of the protocol and then the the format
was designed to be archival to be very
machine reading friendly because we
always imagined that not only our static
paper is boring most of the literature
probably needs to be read better by the
machines than by humans and so we wanted
this document format to be a document
format that was very machine friendly so
that it's a data structure you shouldn't
be parsing it like an animal the way you
have to do PDF to extract metadata out
of it you should have proper metadata
schemas embedded everywhere to
understand what's in there what's
natural language what's code what's an
output what the data is what it says and
then the machines can read most of the
literature which we don't have time to
and we're not reading it anyway because
there's too much of it and then when we
do need one little bit we can get that
little bit convert it to a human
friendly format with the right
conversion tools
so I'll repeat the question for the
recording what's sort of the boundary
between just good more concisely what's
the boundary between notebooks for
analysis and scripting and and one-off
problem exploration versus software
development software engineering
building libraries poking reusable code
it's a very very good question I don't
think we have a full answer to it yet
because I think that answer continues to
evolve I don't think the answer is a
hard no notebook type programming should
stop completely and you absolutely must
switch to a text editor dump export your
notebooks clean them up remove
everything and then make it turn them
into a library I think we I think that
space warrants richer exploration of the
question the tools are not quite there
yet so we've had there's folks in the
Jupiter team that have for example
written hooks using the Python import
hook machinery to allow you to import
code from a notebook now a notebook
tends to have a lot of top-level code if
you naively say read all the code and
run Python import on it it's going to be
a disaster because it's gonna be a lot
of top-level execution but you can do
things like look at it and look at the
ast that it generates the abstract
syntax tree that it generates and say
I'm only actually going to consider
library material class definitions
function definitions and other necessary
things and that's while pullian because
i will assume that if you defined a few
functions in a notebook that may be the
reusable part that
maybe part of five other workflows and
the other top-level stuff where you were
looking at data and making plots that
doesn't need to be a rerun every time I
we import so you can be smarter about
that you can think now I'm not saying
that's the final answer to the problem
but I'm highlighting that to point to
the fact that I think this is a question
that warrants kind of quite a bit of
open-ended of open-ended thinking Knuth
here at Stanford pushes them back since
the seventies on ideas like that the
more traditional literate literate
programming paradigm
I've often referred in deliberate kind
of mirror to that to notebook style
computing as literate computing not
literate programming because you're
often emphasizing I'm computing on this
thing rather than I'm writing a program
but I do think that there is kind of an
analytic continuation if you will
between one and the other what exactly
that should look like I'm not completely
sure I think it's a really interesting
HCI slash tooling question that we
should continue exploring we're kind of
coming out of a long path through the
woods with the development of Jupiter
lab as a UI system that gives us a lot
more flexibility for what kinds of UI UX
machine we put in front of the user I
think we're gonna begin seeing kind of
exploration of this and we're happy to
talk about it but I actually would love
to hear if I don't know if you have any
thoughts because you are a software
developing you remark more on the
software engineering and I do remember
one conversation we had in my office the
first time we met in Berkeley where I
was showing you some of we were
discussing issues about docstrings
in the standard library and interactive
usage and I was kind of running a little
bit of ipython and showing numpy in
MATLAB docstrings and I remember you
said at one point he says oh I see this
is how you guys use this thing you guys
use it we have it's a different workflow
pattern and so you might have a
different take on this and I don't want
I really don't want to monopolize the
conversation so I'm very glad for you
monopolizing the conversation because it
I don't actually have much to add I can
sort of sense that the background of of
the question from I think you said you
work for Google
so I can totally see that some people
who work for a large company like that I
used to work there
where everything has to be under source
control and there are all sorts of bots
that sort of police the source code
that's checked in and then some
developers and especially people who do
a lot of data exploration sort of don't
actually like using the source control
all that much they don't like to have to
wait for code review and so they can can
effectively hide a lot of data in
Jupiter notebooks and this is this is
like a modern version of assist me in a
coroner who had an incredibly large
Excel spreadsheet that contained the
crown jewels of the company that that
was barely backed up and certainly no
one else had access to it and I'm sorry
I don't want to make sort of Jupiter
look bad or anything it's it I can just
sort of see where the question is coming
from because from the from the people
who manage the software engineering side
it's very annoying that that some people
are just circumventing the whole code
review workflow by using different tools
on the other hand from the people from
perspective of the researcher who is
doing data exploration the source
control adds nothing to get workflow it
just adds friction and and so yeah that
I have not much to add except yes this
is a conversation we will continue to
have and and there are probably times
when you want you your entire notebook
on their source control so that you have
a sort of log of lab activities people
who work on patents tend to need to keep
very meticulous logs have been told but
they're also times
when the source control gets in the way
or when after several weeks of making
lots of silly micro commits you just
want to merge it all into a single
commit that says all the new bullying
stop sex that's helpful McWhorter
anybody it's a longer discussion but
okay I can't possibly summarize all that
but the suggestion was to consider multi
representation where you might have two
different representations of the same
data that can be transformed back and
forth without loss and for some people
one representation may be more useful
and for other people the other
representation may be more accessible
and that makes total sense and maybe
Jupiter notebooks and source control are
just two sides of the same coin
but why would software developers want
these Jupiter so the question is why
would software developers use Jupiter my
honest answer is that I have barely
tried it out it's like it's a very
different beast I love watching other
people who are good at it do their thing
with it
I in general don't work with the kind of
data that that requires that type of
visualization and maybe I'm sort of
restricting myself but usually I'm
working on either integration scripts
between different systems or I'm working
on something to do with the core
language implementation and I sort of my
existing tools are are what makes me fly
there I guess the the one thing I'm
certainly not a software engineer but I
have done a reasonable amount of
software development and the one thing
that I did find would and I Python at
its heart did have a lot of features
because I also did use it while doing
just software development and the reason
and and I think this was part of my at
that conversation in 2009 at Berkeley my
kind of prodding about docstrings in the
standard library and whatnot was because
I use ipython in either terminal or in
it's kind of notebook incarnation
precisely as a tool to explore yes and
often its scientific data but if I'm
doing software engineering it's often
just a tool to understand the library so
if I am going to write a piece of code
it's a really handy way of saying load a
library that app completion is superb
and we've made it super powerful and fly
and whatnot there is ways of querying
the namespace in various ways there's
these question mark operators that show
you as much as you can about no it's got
all these little things that basically
it's possible that intellisense and some
of the nice IDs these days have all of
that certainly back in even with a
souped-up Emacs in 2002 2003 2004 it
wasn't quite like that and so for
understanding a piece of software that I
was writing it helped me a lot and for
understanding the ancillary tools that I
might need this in that library and
whatnot so I found it much faster to
import especially in Python right import
something begin tap completing question
marking digging into it and writing like
three line fragments to check it out and
then often just like dumping that to the
screen copy pasting it into a text
editor and then moving on from there so
at that partnership where it wasn't to
explore a data problem but just to
explore a software problem for me was
was quite useful and maybe I was just a
poor user of the off Emacs and and that
I just happen to use the tool that I
knew so the question is whether Jupiter
notebooks are good for snippet
management I've never thought of that
before so I have no idea it's possible
someone has written some little
extension for it but I have no idea
what's the relationship what's the
relationship between Jupiter widgets and
what Jupiter lab Oh notebooks in Jupiter
lab two completely independent things
Jupiter lab is a new UI for what we used
to call Jupiter notebook which when he
opened it was actually an application
that had notebooks and terminals and
text editors and a file manager and
extensions and jupiter lab is a new
application that has all those same
things but with a proper modular system
where they interoperate and they can
talk to one another and you can lay them
out on the screen so jupiter lab is is a
new UI for the things that you would
have done by running jupiter notebook at
the command line before jupiter widgets'
is a completely separate project within
the jupiter world but it's another sub
project to provide interactive controls
in javascript by which I mean buttons
sliders menus checkboxes JavaScript live
interactive controls that are connected
to the Python core and we're actions on
the controls automatically modify the
state of the Python code so there is a
protocol that connects the two it's a
JavaScript layer there's a Python layer
and there's a communications layer
between those and API is in Python to
help you say for example I want to
explore this function this function
makes a figure and there's a parameter a
that I can vary between 1 and 10 and so
you can say with one line of code say
call that function interactively and
make a vary between 1 and 10 with just
one line and then it will make a widget
with a slider that goes between 1 and 10
and as you drag it it will call the
function and plot it so it's the
machinery to give you interactive
graphical controls at a very small local
level it's not for building Photoshop
it's not a GUI framework for writing a
major application it's a way of getting
small quick and dirty interactive
controls or not so quick and dirty the
the machinery does let you build
reasonably sophisticated control
graphical controls but typically
are sort of exploring a specific
question so they're very useful for
education and they're very useful for
kind of scientific exploration that
question always comes up and I am
terrible at it I have like I have all
these stories - sorry the question was
what is the next big thing in Python and
in Jupiter so I always struggle with
that because I know what 10 years ago
what the next big thing was going to be
because by now that has been the most
recent disaster or success but what's
next it's it it always seems to come out
of left field
III just I am bad at predicting the
future I did not see social networks
coming at all and so I don't know some
people are still trying to get the Gil
out of Python but they still haven't
fixed the fundamental problem that a
single-threaded program is twice as slow
and you remove the guilt you mean you
win it back if you manage to paralyze it
at least 4x or so but for a lot of code
paralyzing is is really hard and so
unless you already have a very paralyzed
'like handling lots of concurrent
independent web requests removing the
Gil is not gonna buy you much and we
don't want everyone else's code to slow
down so that's probably not it though
maybe it is maybe we'll we'll have some
some way of getting the best of both
worlds it could be
some future asynchronous world where
we're like all the network libraries in
the standard library actually are
fundamentally asynchronous and the
synchronous calls on top of them are are
just little shims that wait for some
event to arrive that's not where we are
today that's what some people hope to
accomplish I don't know when will Python
4.0 come out is it gonna be in five
years or in 50 you tell me come up with
the next big thing and and our community
will be welcome welcome
welcoming you to to develop it further
oh yeah there - two things that are
complete wildcards are web and mobile of
course at the most recent PyCon there
was a really good keynote by a guy named
Russell Keith McGee
what's that video is all I can say what
he said well I'm also so it's like the
fine print in hedge fund things right
past performance is not a good predictor
of future results so I don't know we do
have a lot of open questions in Jupiter
which one of those will turn out to be
impactful meaningful I'm not sure I'm
probably as bad as almost anyone else as
particularly that but I can also say
what he said watch Russell Keith Magee
story I didn't go to PyCon but the one
thing I watched last week I was giving a
lecture at Columbia and in preparation
for that the one thing I watched was
Russell Keith McGee's talk it is very
good
one of the things that Python has done
an exceptional job with is maintaining
compatibility backwards and forwards and
managing the evolution of the design
what happens in Jupiter now is there how
is that manage is there a process like
the the pet process and the
decision-making that goes on inside of
the Python community and so yeah in fact
we we have a process which is modeled
after the pet process it's called the
Jupiter enhancement proposals and we've
we we have a more complex governance
issue I think in the sense that on paper
it is modeled very closely after Python
we do have we have a structure called a
steering Council
I am nominally the be DFL and this was
modeled directly after that however we
are evolving that and we are evolving
that because the project precisely has
such a complex scope and and I think in
Python has managed to do a kind of a
good job of separating kind of what the
core team worries about versus what the
kind of rest of the community worries on
and other projects in Jupiter a lot of
what happens in Jupiter is come with it
within our scope and so we're sort of
figuring out what are good governance
models to evolve towards for better
managing that but the first
approximation yes we do take we have a
we have similar ways of discussing
enhancements and we do pay painfully
close attention to backwards-compatible
at this point we track the growth of
notebooks on github for example just as
a coarse metric of adoption there's now
millions of them they continue growing
we know that people have invested enough
of their work in building these things
that were not simply going to nearly
really make changes which is hard and
having it's a lot easier to design
software with no users because you know
whatever you want right we now have a
huge responsibility so we can't break
anything the format on disk of notebooks
has changed very little since the very
first one and those changes but they
were minor and the tool knows how to
move back and forth between them and
even though we know today there's issues
well version-control of adjacent data
structures kind of a pain in the ass we
we don't likely take kind of the the
notion of breaking that and coming up
with a new one because we know the
impact would be huge so we think very
slowly about those questions the
question is what about the confused
state and which which means what about
the disconnect between the linear
structure of a document which you can
read top to bottom and the fact that as
you've been executing cells the real
state of the system may be completely
different from that that's a fundamental
problem not of Jupiter but basically of
any notebook type system it was present
in Maple in Mathematica 25 years ago I
think that's another interesting HCI
problem I think fundamentally if you
have and there's good reasons to want a
linear document if that document is
attached to a computationally stateful
entity there's the potential for that
mismatch to exist so the question is how
do you surface it better which one I
don't think we're doing good job and I
think there's good UI ideas that you
could come up with ways of showing dirty
State changing colors indicating to the
users which parts and where where the
execution flow has happened I think
there's a lot of good ui/ux that could
be put into that and second what are the
scenarios where you might actually be
able to afford stronger constraints
where that doesn't happen you can
prevent that from happening if you pay
the price if you pay the price of always
forcing recomputation if you pay the
price a spreadsheet doesn't have that
problem because a spreadsheet recomputes
everything on every change well that's
not realistic in all of Jupiter
workloads because there are many
workloads where like a cell takes five
minutes to compute you can think that
that cell is going to be recomputed
every time you change a ladder down the
road but there may be scenarios where we
computation is viable and the
pedagogical value of not exposing that
complexity warrants paying the price of
recomputation because maybe your smaller
problem small little educational things
so again I think it's a it's a good HCI
research and the UX question
where I don't think we have the final
answer the problem isn't gonna go away
this is the first one that comes up on
every usability discussion question is
anyway my question is how in the very
early stages and I'm also kind of just
curious about those various pages the
only thing both of you said oh how do
you summarize how to build a community
in the very early stages especially if
you have an idea I think that that that
that requires a lot of code to be
written to to start with well some ideas
you may find it easier to get VC funding
and do it in the form of a startup then
do it as an open source project I mean
I'm not sure I can imagine an open
source project that requires the effort
of five engineers for a year I don't
know if that's the sort of the
approximate scale you were mentioning
but something that requires that much
effort before it's it's ready to be
shared
is probably not a great thing to to
start open source at that point you you
sort of you got you got to think smaller
I put like three months in it before I
shared and yeah it was useful at three
months and it was it was not done at
three months but it was useful and so I
know I sometimes read interesting books
about evolution and it's amazing how
very complicated biological systems
could ever have evolved little steps at
a time and yet we know that they must
have evolved that way there are many
many intermediate forms that do not look
as complex as a brain or a heart or even
a dinosaur that that can can sort of be
be made with less effort than five
engineers for a year that that like one
engineer for three months can can put a
dent in some problem and opensource it
at that point or you can can sort of try
to attach yourself to an existing
community not necessarily take over but
sort of get get get people excited about
an idea and I think Fernando probably
has some good things to say as well
actually pressure precious little beyond
that to be honest because I think that
there actually are ways to get funding
if it looks researching off do en SF are
starting to fund
but actually the problem with those
things is precisely that they will fund
you to have ten people working for three
years before there's something useful
and that's the wrong thing to do I I
fully agree with Guido that early push
of mine and I Python when I disappear
was little it was six weeks six weeks
plus the implicit contribution of other
to other people whatever time they had
put into some other stuff but they were
both small I mean all things considered
there were small things small amounts of
code and and that was true it was useful
like that thing that I Python 0.1 on
compliant Python in in December was
useful it was missing a ton of stuff but
it did something and the value of that
is that you get immediate real-world
driven that evolutionary I mean
evolution is driven by feedback loops
evolution is driven by by selection
pressure and you get that selection
pressure early on design in a vacuum is
designed without selection pressure and
you end up with three heads and four
elbows right and so I strongly strongly
encourage anyone to really put out
something that can do something useful
early on even if the full problem seems
to be huge find the piece you can bite
off early and quickly and in the
lightweight manner and what the right
feedback path is gonna be for that okay
I just had one thing to add which is
that if you spend a bunch of time
developing something and then you launch
it expect that your life after the
launch is gonna be nothing like what you
plan for the the sort of the feature
requests what the users are going to
want whether they're going to do with it
is going to be unexpected and that's a
good thing but it means that you must
plan for life after the launch to be
very chaotic and and sort of unplanned
and now there are you said there were
two more questions
so full disclosure I don't use medical
today today but I support the students
and the faculty on the subject of like
submit a notebook as your paper
submission is I'm finding the problem
becomes and it's more than just on books
in general it's not just the notebook
it's the entire environment in which the
notebook runs yeah how do you package
that like you might say and you can't
submit a container because especially in
languages like are they will very
carefully specifically target the CPU
you are building on which is not the CPU
you're running on in the future so this
is a problem that's more than just
notebooks but the reason I bring up here
is because which makes it harder so the
question is about basically
reproducibility and and I do think that
there it's it's a complicated and nasty
enough problem and you've highlighted
issues all the way down to CPU
architecture issues that there's no
there's no known single answer to it I
do think that the combination of
basically what what we're doing with
binder which is the project that tries
to kind of capture that famous quote of
Donna Halbach I didn't clear about about
getting the whole environment or not
just a notebook with the whole
environment and facilitating and
automating the process of creating that
as much as possible is part of the
answer yes it is a container yes it
means that that container is gonna have
some of these issues but there are ways
of for example having the generic the
reasonably generic x86 versions
off of the linkage done so that at least
it runs and it runs in the cloud and and
and I think it's one of those problems
where you have to have a defense and
depth
kind of approach of saying okay well
that that entity that binder is a
container but it also actually has PDF
and HTML versions of the document it has
the code it has the libraries so that
you can do human levels of validation as
well so if some of the layers fail if
the our microarchitecture has changed if
it turns out you needed a wierdo GPU
that doesn't exist in 20 years there's
other levels of human validation that
you can that you can that it can still
do because there is no magic perfect
we're gonna kind of teleport the world a
hundred years into the future and every
every line of code we have is gonna run
I don't have an magical answer to that
one I do have kind of layered approach
to the problem so the question is the
relationship between dubrow widgets and
shiny jupiter widgets as a as a core
project is is just a library right a
shiny kind of has also a deployment
model and a specific website and a
business model around it the jupiter
widgets is the part which is the library
the library and it's not I think today
shiny and I'm not an expert in our so
maybe I'm butchering this I think
originally some of that was very
specifically tied to visualization
Jupiter widgets is a completely generic
architecture around interactive controls
connected on the client to the over a
network protocol to stateful kernels and
in fact they can be implemented in non
Python languages so now Jupiter widgets
has a sequel there's a C++ back-end
julia has a back-end so you can that the
architecture is more generic you can
expose that as a standalone web view
sure there's a project actually out of
the Kwan stack folks who do the C++
kernels called voila that makes it very
easy to kind of expose something like
that we don't have a business model of
running it like shiny that that's a very
specific hosting question the
architecture between Jupiter widgets and
things like
provides all the pieces for that someone
good to the hosting feel free to do it
in any case alright thank you for coming
there's lectures scheduled for every
Wednesday on through the rest of the
year some of them will be fascinating
some perhaps less so but it depends upon
your taste any case it was very pleasant
to have you all here I think we learned
that I'm pleased that the notebooks are
finding a home and I'm gonna write my
next paper that way I think it'll be an
extremely interesting experience thank
you very much
[Applause]